if you haven't subscribed to film
courage on itunes it's not too late you
can visit itunes click subscribe and
type in film courage i am your co-host
karen warden
and i am the guy who has the honor of
sitting across from karen well thank you
yes indeed my name is david brandon
actor sam levine is here in studio sam
has over 50 acting credits on imdb and
we're going to talk to him about how he
books so much work
along with what it's like to audition
and work with quentin tarantino yeah
yeah excited to hear all this coming up
right now on film courage we have with
us actor sam levine his credits
including glorious bastards i love you
beth cooper freaks and geeks the family
guy entourage and much much more
sam thank you hello oh my pleasure thank
you guys so much for having me what a
what a genuine pleasure this is
this sounds like such a highbrow
npr type show and i'm just going to
bring it right into the gutter i love it
i love it great i love when i introduce
a guest and we start off with a smile on
our guest face
and again if you would like to interact
with us on today's show send your tweet
to at film courage okay well sam let's
start out where did you grow up uh i
grew up in the garden state fort lee new
jersey oh very nice very nice and which
part of new jersey is that fort lee is
it's northern jersey it's uh right by
manhattan uh there's the the three main
inlets from new jersey into manhattan is
the george washington bridge the lincoln
tunnel and the holland tunnel and uh the
george washington bridge
fort lee is where that hits new jersey
okay and how young were you when you
developed an interest for acting in
comedy um that's a good question i think
i was i'd always been kind of uh
fascinated by performing and everything
but i remember being
scared
uh to perform when i was 10
years old or 11 years old i i was going
to be in the in the yeah i know i was
going to be in the in the school
my elementary school production of uh of
a christmas carol and i remember the the
music teacher wanted me to play uh
marley
but i was nervous and it's too many
lines i said i don't want all those
lines and i'd rather just be in the
chorus okay and then uh somewhere
between between that year between fifth
and sixth grade i lost that fear and
then
uh demanded to be well hidden demand but
i really wanted to be the lead in the
the following years production which was
the nutcracker
a
non-ballet
version
of the nutcracker that really just
involved a lot of talking okay
interesting one it was very boring why
why do you love acting and then how did
you become an actor i love acting
because it is so much easier than
getting a real job let's be honest here
um i love acting because i'm a very
expressive person um
i i love the idea of of characters of
uh you know mimicry of of uh just being
someone else for however long um in
another life i might have made a good
undercover cop if it weren't for the
being short and jewish and not strong
but um
uh i was i've always been drawn to
performing so it was for me a very easy
decision and you started at a very young
age in terms of your professional career
how young were you started and how did
that come about uh i
initially more so than wanting to be an
actor wanted to be a stand-up comedian
okay and uh when i was 11 years old in
uh in 1993 uh the late uh but wonderful
comedian richard jenny had uh uh an hbo
comedy hour called platypus man
uh that aired and i watched that thing
religious i taped it and watched it
again and again and again and again i
couldn't believe
how great it was
i i thought oh wait a minute you just
get up on a stage
joke around for an hour
people will like you this seems
impossible
and uh and so i wanted to become a
stand-up uh based almost solely on that
and so i spent the next
uh year or so uh you know putting
together my own bad jokes and i'd
memorized all of
uh richard jenny's jokes from platypus
man and uh i believe i actually
performed in my sixth grade talent show
doing
pretty much verbatim one of his bits
from platypus man the the red lobster
sketch or that sketch but the red
lobster material um and uh and then
about
uh less than a little less than a year
after that i began
um playing my friend's bar and bat
mitzvahs okay that was my neck yes and
alisa kudrow that's right yeah lacy
kudrow was was was in the audience if
you will at one of these uh bar mitzvahs
i was playing
and uh and friends was in its first
season it was 94 and and afterwards she
came up and said hey that was really
good you know are you an actor i said no
she said you really should be you seem
like you have the timing for it you
might want to consider pursuing that so
i went home and
look ma lisa kudrow from friends the hit
show friends said i should be an actor
we gotta get on that let's do this thing
very cool well that leads me into my
next question because you know i know so
many people who
come from backgrounds where there's a
lot of pressure to be something
great something with a title that equals
a good living and then those people tell
their parents hey guess what i want to
study acting you know i want to move to
la and and take classes now i realize
you started at a young age but did
anyone in your life
attempt to talk you out of being an
actor or a comedian uh yes both of my
parents attempted to and that lasted
i'll tell you exactly how long it lasted
less than a week uh
uh so i said i want to be an actor we
went and bought uh backstage magazine
which is for new york actors it's kind
of the the new york bible of weekly
publishing um and so uh
we found an ad in there for a manager in
new york who managed specifically kids
who did stand up oh wow
and we i went in to meet with him and my
mother thought i was just going in to
meet with him to rep me as stand-up but
then he also wanted to represent me as
an actor
and uh my mother was not keen on that
idea off the bat because she was aware
of how difficult it is you know to be an
actor at any age
and and you know how often that pursuit
will lead to nothing but heartbreak
and uh
and so i went home
and my parents said we'll discuss it
you know what we'll think about it
and uh and then that either that night
or the next day the manager called and
said uh look uh you don't have to commit
to anything i just i really want to send
sam on this one audition
you know it does it's not going to bind
you guys to me i haven't signed anything
i just want him to go on this audition
see how he does
and my parents said ah fine we'll let
you go on one audition we still have
made up our minds yet i go into one
audition for this toy commercial and i
book it wow
and then they were uh had no problem
with me uh wanting to pursue this uh
this whole acting uh michigan
and i'm not sure and how old were you
because you were incredibly young
weren't you uh i was like 13 or 14. okay
yeah okay okay beautiful
and you know so many actors they make it
look easy yet you hear behind the scenes
that so many great people question
themselves and their talent do you
question yourself as an artist
uh anyone who doesn't question
themselves as an artist is a liar
um i oh i always i hate everything i do
i well no that's not true i hate most of
the stuff i do i don't know because i'm
i'm my own harshest critic okay who
isn't
everything that i've done that i watch
i of course will always go oh why did i
do that i need to do that differently
and then i realized recently that i
probably did do it differently but the
director did not like that take
so the only pro the only thing i could
ever visualize where i'd be in a film or
something where i see it later on and go
i made all the right choices is
something that i would either have to
direct or edit and that's not going to
happen anytime soon so i'm stuck with
hating a lot of the choices
how do you go about preparing for a
character and what's your process
um
you know i
i don't want to belittle people who use
a process okay um because i've always
said
everyone gets to that point their own
way
and there's no one way that's right
versus another way
for me my process most of the time is
very
i read the lines off of the page
you know in my head as i'm you know
preparing for the role and i just know
how they should sound in my head when
they're said out loud
and
when i say them out loud i try to make
them sound as best as i could to the way
i heard them in my head okay um you know
and that's that that's mostly though for
for comedy if i'm doing something
heavier i will put obviously a little
more thought and energy into it before i
you know go to do the scene but i i mean
you know there's there's the there's the
old story
from uh from the set of marathon man
okay um stop me if you've heard this one
listeners um
where uh i i don't know if you know the
movie it's a great movie with dustin
hoffman and lawrence olivier and roy
scheider uh
and uh and so there's this great
climactic scene
with lawrence olivier this living legend
and dustin hoffman who at the time his
late 70s
young kid and um
and hoffman's character is supposed to
have been awake and running for his life
all night
basically before he encounters olivier
his character
and uh and so they get to set that
morning
and hoffman looks terrible
and
olivier says why you look so awful and
often says well you know i'm in this
scene i'm supposed to be you know awake
all night and running around so i stayed
up all night and just kind of i'm going
crazy
and olivier just looks at him and he
says
that's why they call it acting my dear
boy
so okay so you're not going out and and
you know
living
whatever that character is you're not
trying to live it and do the whole no i
am not a methodical that's what i'm
looking for yeah i know a number of
method actors and i have admiration for
them okay um because that i know that's
something i could never do
but uh
everyone's process is different so i i
i feel my process is no more right or
wrong than any other okay you know we
have a shout out coming in from twitter
from justin lyon
yeah yeah he wants to throw you some
high fives sam so he says keep up the
good work well thank you very much
justin high five right back at you
absolutely now what are your current
goals in acting and and do you feel like
you've given your best performance
oh wow uh all right i'll take the first
part of the question
um what are my goals as an actor um
well here's a good story um
uh
for passover the uh the jewish holiday
of passover where we uh retell the story
of the the
slaves in egypt uh getting freed by
moses which we do every year you have to
end that seder that the passover said of
the big dinner by saying next year in
jerusalem
that's sort of the goal when you end the
seder every year whoever's running the
seder says next year in jerusalem
i've always thought you are aiming too
high
we're not going to do the thing next
year in jerusalem why set these
unattainable goals i say next year in
cincinnati because we might actually do
that
that's how i've always felt
as such my goals as an actor are not to
win an oscar or an emmy or make 20
million dollars a film my goal as an
actor is to support myself as an actor
regardless of whether i'm hugely famous
or no one knows who i am if i can keep
putting food on the table by acting
then i have met my goals i truly have
um because again
easier than getting a real job
you see so many people that
have attained a certain amount of
success and they've lost their freedom
and they can't go to the grocery store
anymore or or to a movie
is is that something that you do you
think the money is worth that or would
you rather just make a comfortable
living
but be at a place where you have more
anonymity
um you know that that's a good question
and
i know uh personally a handful of people
who are unable to walk down the street
and i don't envy that you know that's
that's not that that's too bad you know
you can't just oh i'm going to go get
some milk in the middle of the night and
run out and grab them and come back no
they can't do that um
i don't think that's something that i
i really think about um for me
uh because i don't i don't think i'll
ever be that famous and that's not a bad
thing i i like that i can still for the
most part do all of the normal things in
my life that i did before i became an
actor um really the level i'm at right
now is great because i i typically get
stopped at restaurants when i'm on dates
okay that's perfect and that's when you
want to get harassed right there
i'm a big fan i love your work on that
so raven would you sign this napkin for
my daughter
yes i would right
perfect
and and coming back i mean have you
given your best performance that is oh
yes so to come have i give my best
performance i hope not
um as proud of the work that i have done
uh i feel like there is a a lot more out
there in my future
so what do you think is the best thing a
director can do for an actor
um
open questions
slippery slope of a question the best
thing a director can do for an actor is
be
honest with them and
be very willing to
uh
work with the actor on
the character
on the performance
um and and be open to suggestion
um there i've worked with a few
uh you know directors over the years one
of whom i will not name uh
uh specifically but it literally this is
not this is not a joke i in one take i
did said
the and then in another take i said thee
and then afterward
the director sent the script supervisor
over to say no no you have to say the
every time okay tomato tomato yeah and i
said
really
yeah that's what the director wants
the internet every pronunciation uh the
presentation of every single word was
important and when you are that
uh constricted
it some actors thrive in that i'm not
one who does
um
uh and you know then i then i've worked
with other other directors who
say if you hate the line say whatever
you feel comfortable with is what
they'll say you know do you have any
suggestions any anything you think of to
make the scene funnier better more true
to the way you're trying to play the
character go ahead and do it
and for me i'm very comfortable doing
that
um but i also know other actors who
prefer the first way
who prefer to have everything very rigid
and this is exactly what i want from you
exactly this way and they will hit it
every time
and uh you know it's it's
i again there's no really right way or
best way to direct an actor it's always
a little bit different
with every director and every job so
maybe it depends on the relationship
between the actors and the director and
uh definitely whether they need
structure or whether they want more
flexibility
you are listening to film courage we
broadcast live every sunday 11 a.m
pacific standard time here on la talk
radio dot com we are speaking with actor
sam levine uh you know one of the things
that i've mentioned um before on the
show and i'm sure many people can vouch
for this is that you know time moves
very quickly and i've seen a lot of
people myself included who come to la or
new york to become actors and they slip
into a party mode and they hang out with
friends and
they don't focus on their dream and then
time slips away you get a little bit
older and life gets a lot harder and
then there's this realization that's
like wow i'm this age and i'm still
doing this i can't believe this um
what do you think are some of the
mistakes actors make when they get to la
or new york
oh boy
let's hear it
um
all right
i'm
not going to win a lot of friends saying
this david cross uh the wonderful
wonderfully funny comedian david cross
has a a bit on one of his albums that he
calls
uh he calls los angeles
the 24 hour a day non-stop parade of
self-delusion
and i'm not gonna do the whole bit i
think you get the the idea of it right
there
um but i see a lot of that i see a lot
of people who
i i have
strong admiration for people who bust
their ass
trying to
get themselves further in their careers
but at some point if you're busting your
ass day in and day out you've been doing
it for years and you haven't gotten even
a half step closer to that next level
i have always wondered at what point do
you have to make the decision to go all
right
maybe this isn't working out the way i
thought it was
i'm going to start exploring this other
thing i'm not going to forget about the
first thing but i've got to look out for
my future
even a little bit
and i
i feel like
not enough people maybe have that that
little moment of oh i came out here to
be an actor and i'm going to try but at
the same time i don't want to be
40 and broke
um so
i i i mean
but i feel like i'm not being true all
right i i don't want to keep telling
other people's stories but no this is
good this is these nuggets here i uh i
listen to a lot of interviews myself so
so i'm just gonna regurgitate um
but then on the flip side
here's uh here's the the other argument
uh so vin diesel
when uh when he was a young man was a
great admirer of harrison ford
and um
and he was working on some movie that
harrison ford was in i don't know if he
was an extra or had one line or what
have you but he was on set with harrison
ford and
he had he just loved this man so he
waits
weeks and weeks and finally
finds the right moment gets harrison
ford alone and says listen i i have to
ask you
you have a career people would kill for
how did you do it
and uh and harrison ford takes him aside
because i'll tell you how i did it i
moved to hollywood in the 60s
with
five other friends
we all chipped in money we got this
house
and after the first six months two of
them left
after the first year another two left
after a year and a half
the fifth guy left
i never left
leaving was never an option for me wow
okay
and uh and that's how i feel about it
leaving's not an option so
um
you know
i'm not saying if it's not working out
give up move back to your hometown
uh
because i don't want to leave and if
you're here to act you shouldn't leave
because acting isn't in duluth it's here
in los angeles or new york
um
but uh you know i just i i i
have a lot of friends who are in their
30s who can't afford to go see movies
because they're broke putting all they
have into acting and
it's it's only gotten tougher in the
almost 11 years now that i've lived here
i moved to la right at the very end of
what was a very sweet time to be an
actor
tv shows
uh there were was almost no reality
shows or or game shows on television yet
that all started right right at the end
of 99 2000 so tv work was plentiful uh
film work was
booming the the independent movies
had real money
to them back in those days now now they
make movies for fifty thousand dollars
um you know so
it was it was a different time and it's
only gotten harder every single year
that i've been here so i i don't
i wouldn't turn anyone away who wants to
come to la to be an actor but i mean man
it is an uphill battle
you know unless of course you are lucky
enough to have some sort of video on the
internet
and get plucked from obscurity and put
into film that way
i'm not naming names yeah you know
keeping with what you're saying here sam
because
you know i don't want to paint a total
gloomy picture but you know i'm curious
what are some of the key ingredients
that that you have to have or an actor
should have
um that to help nurture your career you
know to put you in a spot where like
these are the things you need to have in
place what would actors out there if
they're just struggling and they can't
find the next audition right
what do they need to have in place fair
enough and i and i apologize for
painting such a gloomy blue no no no but
but it needs to be said it does it does
um well along with what i was saying
before about leaving was never an option
for me that is one of the pieces of
advice i give to younger people who ask
i say the longer you stay here all
you're going to do is build more
relationships and meet more people
and that is invaluable
in getting to that next level because
you can't get to that next level if
people don't know who the hell you are
and so you have to meet them you have to
try to
get yourself in a position to meet these
people whether it be at a party or at an
audition or
at a restaurant you have to
you have to be willing to embarrass
yourself and put yourself out there in a
way that you're going to be rejected
most of the time but that's only most of
the time not all the time
um so
so that is my advice it's it's don't
don't be afraid of getting a little
embarrassed and when you talk about that
rejection i mean
how have you handled those so-called um
dark nights of the soul where where
maybe you question am i going to surpass
this level will i regress will i am i
going to get another audition how do you
how do you keep yourself going uh i
drink a lot
and um
i throw knives uh okay well only one of
those is true um
you know
i'm not a very dark guy in spite of of
what i'm saying like i don't go to that
dark place
um because i i never saw the point of it
okay um
i i you know i i only get upset when
things go bad if it was something that i
had
control over
but if if i've done everything in my
part like if i have an audition and i
put all my you know effort into learning
the lines and working on the scenes and
i go in and i give it my best and i
don't get it there's no reason for me to
get upset because i did everything i
could possibly do it was out of my hands
after that so if it doesn't go my way
why should i get upset about it
um you know that that just seemed uh
silly to me and and i have other friends
who get really upset when when you know
they had an audition it didn't work out
no i should have been my partner
i
you know just not my uh not my game we
have um dresden dolly
please give my boy sam levine a huge hug
from his biggest fan in the midwest
dresden dolly is is lovely she uh
she uh she at replies me on my my
twitter page which is at sam levine yes
and it's s-a-m-m-l-e-v-a-n-e
two wims that's right two m's and you
know and kyle donets has um send the
question but we're gonna kind of touch
on this this is the direction we're
heading in so just just hang in there
but she um she said or i think it's i
heard i'm sorry he he said um it's great
to see in glorious bastards so
we're going to kind of come up on this
here
where does quentin tarantino rank on
your all-time director's list number one
no question about it and
here's uh a great little thing when i
booked inglorious bastards a uh
and i gave an interview talking about
quentin someone dug up an old interview
i had given almost 10 years earlier
uh that someone asked me who is the
director you want to work with more than
anyone and my answer was quentin
tarantino on anything
and uh and so it's good to know uh i am
not a liar nor have my tastes changed in
a decade well how did you learn of the
audition
um
i learned of the audition
uh
i feel like i overheard
someone talking about i was at a party
and i think i overheard people talking
about how quentin was going to start
meeting
young jewish
actors in la
uh for the the roles of the bastards and
it wasn't he wasn't going to read anyone
he was just doing general meetings
where you just go in and shoot the [ __ ]
with them for 10 minutes
so i guess first off it helps that
you're connected to the right kinds of
people or partying with the right kinds
of people that that have this kind of
information uh i guess so yeah
if you think about it that way
um yeah i but
the story actually starts uh within
glorious bastards about five years prior
to that general meeting
okay i uh
and see here this goes back to what we
were just talking about being in the
right place at the right time um
uh
i
have known uh jimmy kimmel
for
nine years now
and uh when he started his late night
talk show in 2003 it became the coolest
place to hang out in la on the
weeknights the green room at his show is
like a club
and um and so i knew jimmy i knew
cousins hell i knew a lot of the people
on the show so any night i wanted to i
could go hang out at the green room and
kind of watch the show from there and
that was a lot of fun
and
when i saw that quentin was going to be
a guest
on one of the shows
i did not waste any time
in
letting
jimmy and company know that i wanted to
come to the show that night so that i
could meet quentin
and uh and so i went and hung out in the
green room and took my time and i knew
that quentin knew uh the show freaks and
geeks that i had been on because i knew
clinton was friends with uh judd apatow
and so i kind of patiently waited in the
green room for the right moment and then
i approached quentin and struck up a
conversation and he knew who i was from
the show well how how large is this
green room and how many people are in
the career it's a pretty big green room
and at any given time there's like 150
people in there oh okay wow yeah it is a
party atmosphere i kid you not it's a
full party yeah and uh and so i waited
for a moment we started talking about it
then i went back to his dressing room
with him and we had a drink and we
talked for like 90 minutes
about freaks and geeks and he was
promoting kill bill at that time so we
talked about that
and uh yeah we had a uh a fun little
encounter and then uh we actually went
up staying there so long that after the
show had ended that security came in and
was like guys we don't want to kick you
out but we want to go home
so leave
okay so it wasn't before that you talked
to him after he came out yeah he had
done his segment on the show and then
came out and hung out afterward and um
and then we walked outside as we were
leaving he said hey man it was really
great talking to you i hope we can work
together someday and i said yeah that'd
be that'd be all right
and uh lo and behold
five years later there we were at that i
i got in that general interview
and he remembered that we'd met and
you know but listen i'm curious how you
know so once once you're at this party
and you hear you hear your friends and
they kind of mention okay quentin's
calling people in for the for these
general meetings you know how do you go
about what channels do you go about to
to get yourself
into a meeting with quentin where where
where do you go well i called my manager
i have an agent and a manager okay and i
called my manager and said quentin is
meeting with young jewish actors
get me in on this
now
there is i'm not kidding around you make
this happen today
and uh they made it happen for you and
they made it happen fairly quickly yeah
okay so
um
and from what i understand so you sit in
it it wasn't an audition right away it's
just this meeting where so yeah just a
general meeting uh just hey what's going
on what are you up to
you know um
so you're jewish you had a bar mitzvah
tell me about that
and because quentin i knew quentin and i
knew each other from you know years
earlier um it wasn't a nice to meet you
conversation it was in hey so what's
been going on
kind of kind of vibe we talked about
freaks and geeks and jet apatow and
undeclared and uh and he requested all
the actors bring in one or two uh
projects that they were proud of that
they wanted him to see and so i brought
in
um an episode of veronica mars that i
had been on that i i was pretty proud of
and i actually brought in a short film
that i uh uh starred in
that i was very proud of and i put those
on a dvd forum and
and so it was really just kind of a a
very loose
relaxed meeting with a lot of the work
that you book
is it done through relationships or is
it mostly done through your agent
manager i mean it sounds like that was a
special case yeah it's about 85 through
my agent manager um but you know some of
the my most favorite jobs i've i've
really ever gotten have been
uh relationship jobs from you know
people that i knew before the job
happened and that's what led to it um
the the movie club dread
that i was in um
i i booked that because i had already
worked with uh jay chandrasekhar the
director of that film on uh two episodes
of undeclared
and so when that opportunity presented
itself i didn't really have to
you know he he called me he reached out
to me
because of that existing relationship
so so most of the auditions that you get
are through your your agent or manager
yes
how important do you think it is for an
actor to build up his or her audience uh
it's very important because they the
fans drive the marketplace if uh if
suddenly
nobody wants to go out and see uh
tom cruise movies
the studios are not going to give him 20
million dollars to keep making movies
so it's very important to to make sure
that you have a fan base but i guess
it's more important to make sure you
have a fan base that's actually going to
go out and spend the money to see the
things you're in
because
well wishes are uh
are nice good intentions no i'm a big
fan you know i download all your stuff
on the internet wait what was that
you don't actually pay for the all right
thanks uh thanks a bunch
say when i when i look you up online i
see a ton of interviews with sam levine
and inglorious bastards linked together
yes um you know and what happened i
guess is your role was significantly cut
down in the final product from what i
hear um and yet you were doing press as
if you were one of the film's leads
right which i love and i admire so you
know so you obviously made the decision
that with glorious bastards you're gonna
go out and get all the press that you
could um can you share with us the
motivators behind this decision uh sure
well the first motivator is when i
started doing press for glorious
bastards i had not seen the film
in its in its finished uh form i
knew what i had shot okay and i had an
idea of what the finished film would
look like so when i first started doing
press i did it under the impression that
the bulk of what i shot would still be
in the film okay um
and then after i saw the film uh at the
cannes film festival and
realized that
most of what i had done
was on the cutting room floor
um and i still had all these interviews
set up i i told my my publicist i was
like you know do they do they know do
they care
and she was like no they are still happy
to have you in there and then i realized
you know brad pitt can't do
every interview promoting glorious
bastards someone else has got a he's got
to do other interviews
and i was more than happy to to to do
them because
even if
i only had you know a walk-on if you
just you know saw me carrying a gun in
one scene i would be happy to promote
the movie because it's a great movie and
the fact that i got to work on it even
if it was just a day
um which it wasn't but even if it were i
would have been thrilled to get out
there and promote it with everything i
had because it it is certainly my most
high profile project to date and a
project that i'm very proud to have been
a part of
so you know let's talk payoff how has
all this press um has it led to you know
auditions jobs
um you know has it paid off in any any
kind of way um
you know uh
that's that is a hard question to answer
um
it's it has led to um i don't know that
specifically the press that i've done
has led to other things yet
i i mean i don't know what the what the
the root of it is if the film was just
popular enough that people saw it and
knew i was in it i don't know that they
needed you know uh to to you know hear
me do an interview to know that i was in
the film
but um
maybe in terms of of fan base
uh it's helped
um i don't know professionally so far
because i think all the the the rooms
that i've gone into and the people that
i've seen since the film opened
um they all told me how much they liked
the film and you know how you know happy
they were to see me in it and and i'm
grateful for all that but i don't i i
think all those people probably would
have seen the film regardless
but in terms of fan base uh i think it's
helped
and and coming back to your audition
with with quentin you know what is it
like
when when you actually when he says you
know what after the general meeting i
want to bring you into him i want to
actually audition you can you can you
take us there
um you know oh yeah the the number one
yeah well that's in your book yeah
that's about that that general meeting
was on a friday afternoon
and uh as i was driving home from that
meeting
uh i got the phone call from my manager
saying that
it went very well and quentin they're
gonna send you a script and they want
you to read it and then prepare some
scenes and come back in monday
and audition for quentin
and uh and originally uh he had me
prepare and read for the role of
yudavitch played by bj novak okay and uh
and so i spent all weekend working on
that i called up a writer director
friend of mine uh and he helped me with
it and um and so i went in monday and
we started doing the scene and when i
say we i mean quentin and me
which is very unusual most auditions the
director will sit there and watch you
read with
either the casting director or an
assistant
i've never been in a room where the
director read the other lines with with
me
um so right there i knew
you know oh god this is such a great
project
and um
and so we read udovich stuff for about
10 minutes
and then
quentin said you know what i i kind of
want to see you read
donnie donowicz
i want to see what that sounds like
and so he gave me the donowitz sides you
know the role played by eli roth and so
i looked over those for a minute or two
and i was familiar with them from
reading the script and and then we
started doing donot scenes
and we did those for another 10 minutes
or so and i mean we're up we're on our
feet we we're walking all around the
room we are staging this scene
and so you know i'm in there almost a
half hour just doing these scenes with
him and he says you know what that was
great i i think i saw everything i need
thank you so much for coming in i really
appreciate it i said yeah of course
and i split and then we don't hear
anything for two weeks
i figure it's all over
and then i get the phone call that they
want me to play hershberg
a role i did not read for of course
now
you know when you're doing these lines
with them do you both have scripts in
your hand yeah we were both holding uh
sides which are just a couple pages you
have the sides yeah what kind of
performance was was quentin giving you
was he was he really giving you
something to work off oh yeah he was as
intense as as the guys who did the roles
were i mean that's his baby he's not
going to half-ass it in there he he
never does i'm just trying to imagine
balancing that in terms of you know
giving the performance and then and then
having to be able to step back and
analyze what you're doing as well um
well that's why he's the man genius he
can do all of those things
easily there's one other thing i want to
point out here sam you know in a
previous interview
um you had this quote and i want to
touch on this because i lie a lot in
interviews
by the way this is something that that i
actually was trying to put in the words
with karen this week and then as i was
getting prepared for this interview i
came across this quote
and i was hoping to get some maybe some
commentary on this um you said everyone
has their own thing that only they can
do you know
there's got to be that the one character
that comes up that when you play that
character
you're the only person who could have
played that character that way and when
that happens when that magical click
happens the right actor finding the
right part in the right film or
television show that's where i think you
can get bumped up to the next level
man that's a good quote huh
let's just take a moment to appreciate
how meaningful that quote is and i i
must have been drunk when i gave that
one
um yeah i uh i agree with what i said
my my views on that have not changed
since whenever i said that you know
because i have a lot of friends that you
know they're pounding the pavement you
know what i mean you know they're kind
of like the you know some of the friends
that you mentioned where you know
they're doing all they can they're
they're doing whatever they can to get
the audition get themselves in the room
and they're doing whatever they can to
get themselves to the next level
you know it just you know it it
i i feel for you guys i feel fractures
and and and the struggle that's there
um
you know and and i love coming across
this
this quote of fine and do you feel like
you you have have you found your your
right role um i don't know that i found
the one if the what what when you read
that back to me it evoked maybe like a
specific thing
um you know like jim carrey as ace
ventura
i mean that when he played ace ventura
prior to that he was just the guy from
living color when he did that role in
that movie can you imagine anyone else
doing ace ventura no and it was the
right actor in the right role in the
right film and bam he was a huge star
after that and so that's what i'm
talking about when i mean the right
actor finding the right part to get to
the next level so i don't know that that
specifically has happened to me yet but
certainly i've had a couple of of roles
i mean the role of neil schweiber on
freaks and geeks
um you know albeit ten years ago now was
huge for me uh prior to that i was just
an obscure you know new york actor
trying you know doing commercials and
trying to get bit parts in in whatever i
could and so actually i almost wanted to
say that i don't want people to think
that
um you know i i've gotten all these
lucky breaks i absolutely had my hard
times when i started as an actor yes i
happened to be a teenager but the the
struggle was was still the same
um i mean i i struggled for
over five years
um trying to get anywhere as an actor
before i booked freaks and geeks and if
the pilot for freaks and geeks had not
gotten picked up
i would probably still have stayed in
new york for a long time after that
working at it because i would not have
i don't know that i would have had the
the gumption to move to l.a
than i you know um but uh
but you know it's uh and how much work
you know because you know you have over
50 jobs that you've booked as an actor
how many would you attribute to freaks
and geeks you know how how big has that
been for you um
wow i i i mean
uh you know if i'm from from an ego
standpoint i want to say none
i wanna say i have booked every job
since then on my own accord on my own
awesome talent but i don't know i mean
uh i know
uh i know clinton was a big freaks and
geeks fan
so i'm sure that played uh no small part
in you know getting him to consider me
for for bastards um
i don't know i mean you know it's not
often uh once you get cast in something
someone will say
uh oh i cast you in this because i
really loved you in freaks and geeks
you know i mean they might think it but
i've never really heard anybody say that
um so i i couldn't i couldn't say i got
you i got you
um you know so we're heading we're
heading into our last couple minutes my
god is it really yeah we just
i could talk all day i should charge for
this like that kevin smith does you know
has this conversation this dialogue that
we're having here in studio has it
evoked any additional thoughts you know
anything you want to leave to anyone
that's going to be tuning in here
listening yeah i really feel like i
haven't cursed or said enough foul
things um i really haven't disgusted you
guys which is
which is my goal on a sunday morning
um
i mean i i had a whole riff on anal
bleaching i was going to go into gonna
have to forget about that now
um
no i uh i don't know i i guess
uh i'm i'm worried that i made it sound
really bleak and i don't want to
discourage
any
uh young people who who are considering
acting um
but i i i definitely will stress it is
the hardest uphill
battle
of your life um
in terms of
you know uh
a career trying to to build yourself as
an actor it is it is not easy the
setbacks can be
very uh painful
um but
you know like like harrison ford said
leaving can't be an option if it's an
option at all
do anything else with your life i say
because you will have more fun
well said
we appreciate your realism
well we've been speaking with actor sam
levine sam thank you so much you know
time is flying or flown by so fast and
um you've mentioned that you have
numerous uh pieces of uh press on
yourself where should people go if they
want to find out more about you that's a
good question um
i don't know find me on twitter or
facebook uh
or uh i should really set up some sort
of web page for that shouldn't i okay so
imdb imdb has a list of uh some some
films that i have coming out uh uh next
year one of them's out right now on ifc
on demand it's called made for each
other um hopefully people can check that
out and i have another film called
drones coming out next year
uh yeah very nice okay so that that's
sam with two m's that's right sam levine
you can find i think it's just like that
on twitter sam you know at sam levine
and i guess look him up on facebook as
well sam thank you for joining us very
much my pleasure thank you well thank
you again for joining us this sunday
this has been another episode of film
courage on la talk radio dot com have a
great week
you